[Musik]
ein bergbauernhof am abhang des pilatus
gemeinde schwarzenberg
hier fließt der giessbach objekt eines
erbitterten streits
[Musik]
bei peter ott gegen die behörden
so läuft das schon seit 30 jahren
[Musik]
es ist eine wie es scheint endlose
geschichte jedem bauern den namen
behörden schreck eingetragen hat behörde
sind sicher gefallen
mehrere richter seiten der cdu
25 jahre im amt aber so eine hecke
trainiert und ich muss sagen es ist
sicher zieht das erscheinen wo es ist
sehr wichtig war
da ist immer ein strafverfahren ein
anstehender prozess oder ein urteil
gegen das sich peter orth wird werden
muss erste schweizer seit ich bitt und
die und ich geh einfach da
es kommt vielmehr macht und bis zur
oberen ich würde aber das wollen wir
gehört zu dem wirklich ruhiger und das
wort installiert und all die anderen nie
wirklich engagierten ich mich wäre
[Musik]
das gis bachtobel bildet auf einer länge
von 600 metern
die grenze zum hof von peter ott eine
unstete grenze wenn der wildbach reist
immer wieder stücke vom land weg für den
zuständigen kanton luzern wäre eine
umfassende bach verbauen viel zu teuer
deshalb macht es der bauer selber was er
aber nicht darf in 30 jahren zählt ihr
den bach legte das bachbett höher
um die energie zu bremsen
oder war das ganze bachfeld
nachforderung 4 und gerät rosenberger
die 20 meter dürfen sie nicht jeden
steinbrocken hier hat er versetzt selbst
riesige felsstücke hunderte tonnen
schwer hat er mit seilwinden in die
richtige lage gebracht
doch ganz stoppen lässt sich die erosion
nicht noch immer stürzten teile seines
landes ins tobel und weiteres material
hängt in der luft
[Musik]
die jahrzehntelange kampf des peter orth
ein verbotener kampf sagt der kanton
walter bauer widerrechtlich ein
öffentliches gewässer veränderung
es war im jahr 1995
der streit mit dem kanton war damals
bereits voll entbrannt
[Musik]
der handwerker lag das holz und gab kurz
nach diesen aufnahmen musste peter ott
erstmals ins gefängnis
seine frau war nun auf dem bergbauernhof
auf sich allein gestellt besonders für
die kinder waren es belastende
erfahrungen der vater im gefängnis
getuschel in der schule chauffiert hatte
1965 einen eigenwilligen mann geheiratet
nach acht tagen konnte peter ott das
zentralgefängnis in luzern wieder
verlassen noch immer einen stall
kleidern er bei seiner verhaftung
getragen hatte ich habe nicht alles kann
ich daheim man nicht auch einen
fernseher radio lose zieht die klasse
mit duschen rasieren also gut an
aber auch dass ich schöne noch er
brauche nun ihr castroper zeigen oft gar
ganz einfache politische seite zu
richten und der steine mir technik wird
dazu eine prächtige test ich will kein
anderer nach kuba dabei nicht nur mit
kein bundesrat dusche wo kantonsrat
sowieso nicht gut meinte rummenigge
der vater von peter bauer und burmeister
im kanton schwyz von diesem hat er
gelernt wie mit wilden bächen zu
verfahren ist beispielsweise wie
abrutschende hänge zu stabilisieren sind
die tanne soll in eine runde gesetzt
werden um die erosion aufzuhalten die
natürlichste verbauung die man überhaupt
machen kann sagt peter orth
allerdings klappt es nicht auf anhieb
auch weil der backe etwas überfordert
ist von der aufgabe
ja wir haben ist einfach zu jung
doch nicht nur da war als der sieben
täler buback interviewt oder für die
jahre toten durch die schweren
niederschläge grössere premier tour
peter ott musste in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten dreimal ins gefängnis dass
mehrere monate die behörden haben im elf
wacker weggenommen und noch mehr
kettensägen und clou das ist einfach
blödsinn wollt ihr machen die politiker
scharf gewesen
mit dem biowetter damit die maschine
oder das signal und nun ist auch der
zwölf die bagger weg frische
reifenspuren vom vorabend als polizisten
das schwere gefährt geholt haben um mit
diesen auch gleich peter orth
heute bringen sie den berg bauen zurück
er verbrachte die nacht in einer
polizeizelle
bei der verhaftung hat es eine rangelei
gegeben
der alte mann hatte eine krücke gegen
einen polizisten erhoben
ermittelt wird nun auch wegen drohung
war nach auszug suchen wir nach waffen
gesucht gefunden werden keine polizei
oder das wird mir einfach ist zum vater
hoch gekommen war am vortag bei der
verhaftung dabei und das ist ja das
hieße ja dass sein büro büro seit das
lang
der hof überlangen er 1979 ist das
ehepaar ott ins jahrhunderte alte haus
eingezogen
das sind sehr einfache wohnverhältnisse
in denen sieben kinder groß gezogen
wurden sechs buben und ein mädchen
und da war immer dieser streit bei der
verbauung des baches hatte peter ott
gelegentlich auch bäume aus dem nächsten
wald geholt aus wäldern der nachbarn im
dorf hat er daher nicht viele freunde
erlaubt sind und wenn die schale so gut
weil ich sicher kein bösartiger die zeit
sind die besondere gesetz nur sind die
rau wie einfach nieder geschrieben dass
ich das problem um ändert wenn wir die
schlussbilanz wtc ist aber geändert
sodass sie ist für raub der wie nah das
problem löst die existenz vermieter
gefördert und weiteren sinne der familie
war dass das sieht auch wenn er die tour
ihren eigentlich hier können wir machen
so sieht peters ehefrau wohnt schon seit
einiger zeit unten in schwarzenberg die
umstände der ewige streit um den
giessbach vor allem haben sie krank
gemacht was ist wegen
nein ich muss man sagen das müssen wir
jetzt sehr schutz und und das land auf
jeden fall seebach aktien oder aktien
das ist dass ich lieber setzte das kann
nicht wirklich als 1000 zurückkomme
glaube dass alles und cromford und dass
das kam schon nach regelmäßiger
herzschuss besuch von ihrem mann und
gelegentlich fährt die frau nach oben
macht dort den haushalt distanz hatten
beiden gut getan hat neue nähe
geschaffen
den rummel um ihren mann jedoch während
jahrzehnten in zahllosen
zeitungsartikeln ausgebreitet den
vermisst sie nicht noch einmal keine
noch so aber auch im alleingang aus
das gis bachtobel gibt nie ruhe erneut
hat peter ott ein stück land verloren
das ist jetzt der rutsche frisch frisch
auf frisch und wenn wir es täten die
runde hat es geschafft hat oder der hand
da war das nicht passiert das ist das
werk von material gummierung eigentlich
braucht zum wieder behalten das ist sehr
gut die muss in baku sekunden zu regnet
und der guard tyrese mehr user und
kämmerin der stadt genau da
[Musik]
und dies ist peter ochs methode den
rutsch hang zu beruhigen wieder zu
gewalt holzpaletten werden mit langhaar
bedeckt samen schlagen aus verfestigen
die grundlage schließlich wachsen weiden
daraus der kanton jedoch sagt das sei
eine deponie ja dass das sage dir das
sage dass ich bald sehen wir das thema
und erwachsen und ballett oder holz das
ist steigend oder das vermuten der pause
20 freeskier und die das humus aber und
das war ja im auto sei die methode mit
den holzpaletten hat in den letzten
jahren bereits große grünflächen im
abhang geschaffen und doch dreht sich
der aktuelle streit mit dem kanton um
die frage ob das eine deponie sei 30
jahren und buch diese auseinandersetzung
mit polizeieinsätzen verurteilungen und
auch gelegentlichen freisprüchen seit
einigen jahren muss sich beim kanton
michel 4 damit befassen warum bloß ist
ihr nie ein ende dieser unseligen
geschichte geglückt persönlich aber kann
ich die große erfahrung von peter
erismann sie auch wieder einfach hin und
der beobachter sehr gut was abgeordneten
irrt und was nicht
für mich hat motivation besetzung mit
immer nicht unendlich weit weg zu sein
muss ich mit den anderen tag merken dass
einige versicherer vor die nase gehalten
gesetzeswidrig sind sprüche die
ablagerungen im hang oder das zuführen
von material der wahl gesetzlich
verboten ist
zwei jahre zuvor hatte auch der kanton
einen anlauf genommen um das gis
bachtobel zu bewahren
die farbigen pfosten markieren stellen
wo gruppen kleiner lerchen gepflanzt
worden sind
das ist das hundertste so dass ich jetzt
noch nicht aber das ist jetzt auch ihre
tochter wurde vom steinschlag dank dem
bauernhof und dank dank der dem
steinschlag schutz
dann hole ich gemacht habe doch lieber
kommt peter ott einen bach runter um
nach kleinen tierchen ausschau zu halten
kaulquappen
ja das ist einfach beruhigend und
nachher wenn ich wenig aus wie der
polizei dank eines der gefürchteten
pilatus gewitter lässt den giessbach
anschwellen
das lockt peter orth an den rand der
schlucht
könnte ihre rockige flur und der arzt
bestimmt und das wasser dort natürlich
immer kollegen und der szene nur selten
richtig machen woher wird nicht statt
oder was ich spur
[Musik]
es ist die neueste baustelle des peter
ott die zufahrtstraße zum hof droht im
giessbach tober zu verschwinden
nach der methode die er vom vater
gelernt hat wird die rutschen die stelle
stabilisieren nur diese bauarbeiten sind
bewilligungspflichtig und bis jetzt hat
sich ort mit den gemeindebehörden über
die maßnahmen nicht einigen können
die während einfach das eben noch
verwirrter und haben gesagt wenn er das
machen aus mühe ford rutscht da höre ich
sofort auf das machen und wenn wir das
machen was wir sind da im clinch
miteinander
nun macht der bauer hat nur die
notwendigsten sicherungsarbeiten damit
ihnen die straße nicht ganz abhanden
kommt dienlich ist dabei ein
optionspaket wenn er sich nach
beschlagnahmung des letzten wieder
angeschafft hat wie finanziert der
bergbauer diese vielen bagger käufer
ein abteil fache bescheidener und die
führenden frau sicher nicht leichter wo
sich die anderen was könnte in einigen
wochen wird sich die polizei auch diesen
bagger holen
immerhin ist dann wird die straße
zumindest notdürftig repariert sein
die verbauung der sqeez machthabers
hätten kanton millionen gekostet
unverhältnismäßig viel allein wegen
eines bergbaubetriebs und so tat das der
bergbauern notgedrungen selbst und das
nicht mal schlecht
was ihn jedoch zum gesetzesbrecher macht
alle beteiligten wollen richtig handeln
das resultat ist ein versagen der
vernunft der einsame kampf konnte petra
ott nicht verbittern für das als mehr
bestraft und bin ja ich fang nicht
ablesen
ich bereue überhaupt möglich wie sogar
stolz auf das ganze zeug und ich gemacht
habe
jetzt kommt das als wachst das und
landete aber unter bach sieht auch
relativ corpus müssen es besser machen
[Musik]
die kühe sind von der alb zurückgekehrt
die gewendet sieht hier die visage unter
streit dauert an
es ist eine eingabe ans bundesgericht zu
verfassen
ein lebenskampf in ordnern verpackt
dokumente des scheiterns und deshalb
auch kein göttlicher beistand in drei
jahrzehnten ist es nicht gelungen einen
ausgleich zu finden zwischen dem
legitimen bedürfnis berg bauen sich vor
land verlust zu schützen und dem
anspruch des staates auf durchsetzung
seiner regeln wie lange will peter ott
noch weitermachen
das hält mich das letzte mal auf der
mord stadtrand die staatsanwalt die
nämlich dass auch fraglich ob 20 oder
weniger
[Musik]
[Applaus]